I hope that was his cock,
you stupid cunt.
I'm not gonna let cunts
wind me up.
You'd be safe,
tubby little ginger cunt.
Fucking fat cunt.
Eating like a fucking slug.
Don't come out,
this fat cunt shat himself.
He's got
such an important job
as a full time cunt.
You're a cunt. You are.
You are, you're a cunt.
I'm gonna… little bit…
little big belly, you cunt.
You big fucking cunt!
He was shouting at a bloke
with a baby
in the cafe the other day,
everyone looking,
-called him a cunt.
-For very good reason.
-Why?
-He was a cunt.
Daft cunt. Cunt. Cunt.
Cunt. Cunt. Cunt.
-You cunt. Cunt.
-See you next Tuesday.
You're not wrong there,
fucking snot curdling cunt!
They're cunts.
And when
I out leave one of them,
they bring a new cunt in
to take their place.
Cunts!
Simon is a cunt.
Dad, say, "Simon is a cunt".
Perky this morning,
though, hey?
Called Simon a cunt.
-Did he?
-Oh, you silly cunt!
-Silly cunt.
-You silly cunt.
-Billy the cunt.
-Oh, it's Sunday, you cunt!
Oh, you cunt!
-Oh, you dumpy little cunt.
-He was a cunt.
Smashed the granny
out the cunt.
-Little cunt.
-Little cunt!
-Gruffy cunt.
-You're a cunt.
-Cunt. Cunt.
-Cunt!
You will never hear me
use that word.
Absolute cunt.
I'm so proud of you.
I hope that was his cock…
you stupid cunt.